okay so hello everyone and welcome to
the genetics and genomics virtual event
and my name is Monica College I'm a
group leader a good University in
Frankfort and I'm also the chief
scientific officer of the doubloon a
recent spin-off of the good University I
will be presenting total a synthesized
crisp ecology or anus or functional
interrogations and single and multiplex
formats for you today
and please feel free to submit questions
during my presentation and I will follow
up with you after a presentation being
the first of all I would also like to
thank that route for giving us the
opportunity to present ourselves here in
this audience and for those that would
like to get more information please
visit us on the web or contact us
directly so let's get started I'd like
to take a few first words and just
introduce ourselves briefly and we are a
very recent spin-off of liquid
university with even dica jazz our
executive casting caucus operating
officer and myself as chief scientific
officer our main mission is Vivian is to
provide single and multiplex low and
high diversity Chris Picard or RNA is H
RNA libraries and I will briefly
introduce to you two data technology
that we are using and also what we can
do with these reagents and what you can
do actually with these reagents
so this brings me already to a few
introductory words when we talk about
CRISPR applications of course we mostly
as you will see on the left-hand side of
the slide talk about the Whitehead
headline and in this case that peak as
nine and they were basically a guide
will be delivered to a single cell and
then induce the double strand break
which is what we today as understand as
conventional gene editing to perform
single or unbiased gene screens but of
course the technology also enables much
more than that when combining for
example with a inactivated cat nine
enzyme or a dead enzyme we are able to
perform based editing today RNA
targeting we can change chromatin
topology or what even visualize
chromatin we can change the epigenome
and of course I dead I also include
Chris by a interest for I for the
regulation of specific transcript or
gene
M so when we talk about a generating
reagent for single or even screening
purposes of personal casts and there if
you carry it that that I would like to
point out to you especially when it
comes to the generation of the libraries
for grna and both of most of us if we
didn't generate libraries today we sort
of depend on PCR and conventional
cloning techniques and that's not
surprising because when we want to make
a highly diverse reagent like for
example a genome-wide library then the
material that we get off the synthesizer
is fairly limited and what that means is
what that results do is actually that we
have PCR amplify our product and then
this is sort of this is a natural step
and buy-in and what that means is that
we introduce sort of apt our buyers into
the distribution of our sequences so now
that we have our PCR product we need to
digest with restriction enzymes or we
apply or do homework G based cloning
nevertheless what we have to do is we
have to take our PCR product and put it
into somewhat open chromatin or plasmid
and this is the second problem this is
very good cloning artifacts and when we
now close those by
commodity cloning or by the light bases
like t4 for example then and then
transform them into bacteria we will get
artifact which either has no guide RNA
or truncated versions of our plasma and
this is them what we basically call it
our plasmid pool is or or find a library
which will then of course also be
sequence and and this by sequencing we
will only look at the part that we are
really interested in so we were not
sequence for example all the artifacts
that are in the plasma core as well so
by saying that what I'm trying to say is
that really conventional technologies as
of today depend on PCR amplification
steps they do require a restriction
enzymes because we have to open our
chromatin and as I said any conventional
drilling step and until we get our
plasmid pool of which we then later
generate our lentiviral pull it for the
actual experiment so as I already
alluded to the PDI including that can
really be a bottleneck here because when
we take for example reagents that have
that are published and that are out
there and from distributors then and we
really just look at the quality the
diversity and distribution of these
libraries what we see is that for
example a several of those with orange
the yellow them and the blue especially
here that they have a certain
distribution which is which is different
then then from for example every agent
that we have generated with our
technology that I will allude to you in
a little bit and that refers to the FDA
library so what you see on that graph is
what we call a low length plot and that
basically visualizes the distribution or
the evenness the uniformity of a library
and the most less this this curve is
that the better or evenly is this
reagent distributed furthermore what is
highlighted here is also what we can
calculate
the area under the curve we'll just for
the FDA if you look at this is 0.57 so
the area under this curve is 0.57 and
the closer it gets to 0.5 it's the more
evenly this together
and you can see that the previously
established reagent there are less good
distributed than for example a religion
that we have generated the other thing
and despise distribution disadvantages
thing to PCR
I already mentioned our cloning artifact
and this is shown here exemplified by by
Betty upward reaction and word Legation
reaction using conventional current
methods and what we observed is that
only roughly about half of the clones
that we then pick from a plate and find
a sequence and verified by also by the
digest that you can see here and we're
correct and this is examples
demonstrated by the lower band after
restriction digest while several
clones for example in Lane 2 or in 99 or
even 9 17 17 and short complete
artifacts which are based into the
cloning procedure and those are will
always be in your plasma pool and may or
may not generate virus and thereby
affect your library so and so there are
some cabbages by using PCR and
conventional cloning and I would like to
share with you the protocol that we have
come up with that completely circumvent
the need for PCR and cloning and this is
exome exemplified here in an easy scheme
so what we can do is we can take any
plasmid with or without test mine and
only I expressing plasma as a throne
expert in plasma tour
eating a encoding plasmid and convert it
into a single stranded piece of DNA so
what we do is we take a double strand
character away we turn it into a single
string and then we take this single
strand which is now this gray sort code
what we do is we anneal illegal
nucleotides to it with five and three
prime homology and the triangle in that
orange arrow indicates the new sequence
that we would like to integrate so now
we don't do PCR but instead what we do
with me X we extend this primer to all
what its own tail they're generating a
hit will duplex off in gray the oil
template strand and an orange the newly
synthesized strand so the trick here
really is that this gray template strand
is chemically modified and it's
chemically modified in a way that
enables us during the transformation
that bacteria will recognize that
modification and then will degrade this
great strength and only amplify the
newly synthesized orange strand and
thereby basically produce the final
library in a poet manner so again let's
take this this product is very rapid it
only takes about two hours and it does
not involve any PT assets no restriction
enzymes we don't have convention
including of course we have bacterial
amplification but not allegation
mediated chroming and it's very very
very rapid and it is versatile as it
does not it's not limited to only Chris
podcast but as I said before it also can
also be used for shRNA for example or
CDN so does this really work and it's
shown on the next slide and first what
we tested this we tested if we can use
previously published CRISPR cast lire
plasmid and
pestered if we can convert them into a
single strand DNA and that's shown here
we use as a positive control means PTEN
a3 and I hope you appreciate that the PT
dentistry double strand correct around
the the doublet or triplet band and then
the single strand for my grades much
better as a singular band likewise to
conventionally used prospectus climate
the Pawlenty guide and P and D crisper
version two and double strand as well as
in single run correct as an Australian
that we really can efficiently generate
single strand DNA of dollars plan we
then went on and have formed a test
synthesis on these two plasmids shown
here with a pool of six illegal
nucleotides and these illegal
nucleotides encoded for Jia Jia Jie RNA
sequences targeting GFP as of those are
mini quirks with six guide we have
formed the synthesis and the synthesis
product as shown here on the job we then
purify this and transform it into
bacteria as I alluded to before but then
what we did initially is we test that
individual clones if they're contained
the correct sequence and this is shown
on the bar graph on the first bar graph
and around 80 percent of the clones were
correct
while 20% roughly contain the Whitehead
sequence of the our template plasmid so
then we basically went a step back and
we introduced a a dummy
DNA sequence and coding for an is c1
restriction enzyme side and to get rid
of any white and remaining remnants in
our pool and when we then basically take
our plasma pool and clean it up with
this restriction enzyme then I hope you
appreciate and this is the second bar
that any of those clones that we now
look at it
now the
we mutated one and there's no wife has
left on this proven which only 6gf grna
of gfp targeting G on it we then perform
next-generation sequencing and to
basically see what is the distribution
in this library and auto get better
solution and I hope this is on the very
right time shown here this is NGS data
and what plotting here are the six
individual DNA sequences against their
copy number unlock ten measures and I
hope you appreciate that each of them
has been identified nearly uniformly so
there was no apparent bias toward one or
the other sequence so that that was that
was very interesting and then positive
result and then we went on and took
those those sequences produced
lentivirus of them and applied them to
solve expressing gfp and this was shown
here within t7 and the nucleus as they
demonstrating the functionality of these
constructs either in untransformed cell
so this would be the first line with the
- or self transduced with virus encoding
foreign non-union target sequence as
well there was a as you can see there
was no editing however when we edit and
in a single gfp targeting guys we could
identify substantial editing and just
could be further enhanced by using the
pour that we approve that we generated
before and also demonstrate and we even
observed multiple bands popping up
really indicating that all of these
guides potentially have cutted and
basically shredded of the GFP liquid so
this was fine this was a fast function
evidence on the genomic DNA which then
of course also translated to the protein
level when we then move the same cell to
the facts what we observe is basically
in non-human target controls as 100% of
B cells or GFP positive while in the GFP
poor transfused
assault we had a dose-dependent
reduction engineer team over time
demonstrating now that these other
agents were functional on genomic DNA
then of course also translated to the
protein level so that was great because
we now had a technology attempt that
would generate us each reagent and we
didn't know at the time if it will be
suitable also for generating libraries
so what we did is we tested this and the
way we tested it is by mimicking library
diversity is using randomized illegal
nucleotides in primer sequences and this
is shown here on the left side we
designed a
oligo nucleotide for N or 1 to 9 and and
diabetic in limiting and diversity of
265 I'm tell to two hundred and sixty
thousand different oligonucleotide so
the beauty here is that this individual
illegal nucleotide can be purchased from
any oligonucleotide provider and
basically they guarantee you the full
diversity and so we talked we ordered
those six oligonucleotide and perform
the synthesis and also sequence then
these reagents and this is shown IAM the
writer against the Logan Quatro in
uniformity of this reagent and I hope
you appreciate that the reagents were
fully complete and they're very nicely
distributed so now what we did also test
at the time was if this is only due to
randomized nucleotides libraries but or
also to linear encoding libraries and so
what we did is we also generated a
library targeting or a human doback with
mating enzymes which is shown here on
the right hand side the bottom in a
greenish color
generated this library in the patent
area under the curve of prom pixel and
demonstrating very nicely the
distribution of this library so but what
was the most important conclusion for
our here is that the technology that we
have uncovered equal diversity from
sequence distribution which is
independent
different from conventional cloning
where the more reagents you would like
to clone simultaneously who put the
worse basically the quality of your
final product is but with this
technology this is not the case it is
basically in doesn't matter if you have
a single sequence that you would like to
integrate or for 100,000 sequence at the
quality of the situation will be the
same so why buy this iPhone slide I
would like to conclude that the 3cs so
we call it 3GS because what we do in in
this web-based technology is we generate
covalently closed circular synthesized
libraries and we can do this in any
order of complexity and that these
reagents are unbiased then we went on
and took this that library that I just
mentioned and what we did is we
generated of course Lenti viral
particles of it and which have formed
the screen a drop out screen with these
particles and the scheme how we did it
as shown here we applied in my of point
two in an experimental coverage of 1000
we use H third immortalized RPE one cell
and we waited two days after the
transduction to take a day zero or a
control time point and then apply if
your amazing selection pressure I waited
another 11 days in yet another twerk
that another 10 days so we have two time
points esa 11 in day 21s which we then
harvest itself and also extract it to
genomic DNA and we went on for
sequencing and first of all what we did
of course we compared our biological
replicas which is shown here and how
they correlate it and by DT for de 0 on
the left side for daily living
and full-day 21 on the right side hope
you appreciate that over a square as and
Spearman correlations are very high
about 29 and demonstrating a very high
experimental reproducibility with this
reagent and of course high reversibility
also let us then to perform drop offs
and a dropout analysis or his calling
and this is shown here on this slide for
each day we were then able to identify
the ubiquitinated that either enforce a
positive fitness effect or and negative
fitness effect and this was interesting
because I put your attention to day 11
and day 12 USP 28 was always a very
positive fit which was already known
from the literature but for example brtt
3 or us p 9y remarkable amount to
enforce for a positive effect so there
was nobody here but also we could
confirm negative effect of that like for
example Cortes takes us b7 or PSM d 14
interestingly the since we took two time
points we were also able to identify
identify phenotype types that may change
over time and as demonstrated on the
right hand type for example USD 20 ice a
both strong as a 11 but what even for
what was even stronger at day 21 which
why is it was a really strong hit in
term when it changed up in italics on
the right hand side and I just mentioned
a few and of course non-human target
sequences were always sort of like in
the border of being and being
significant as they were our controls to
sum up this experiment we then of course
identified enriched and also defeated
cubic with a laser that is shown here we
were then able to use this information
and apply our technology to generate
shRNA reagent this is shown on the right
side that we then use in an independent
approach to basically confirm or
validate the phenotypes that we had
identified with our reagents before and
we use the Lucifer rate as a negative
control and the period one targeting
shrnas positive control for dropper and
I hope you appreciate that we could re
identify us be 28 BR TC 3 4 as in using
a positive effective while us b7
copper86 the way identified validated
tool use and negative effect to what is
now enabled us ready to do is a positive
and negative screening and of course we
can use the technology to generate the
shRNA or grna validation reagent we will
come this way quick app of course on an
educational purpose there are different
levels in terms of what is needed and
what is equipment and needed and what
the type of these experiments I would
like just like to walk with you with
this work quick so of course easy
phenotypes are for example survivor or
sensuality which am busy p.m. translate
into a dropout or an enrichment screen
the library format in this case and what
is mostly poet and the instrumentation
you needed would be would be
next-generation sequencing for medium
level screens of course we are also
considering this an on and off phenotype
that we can solve for example if we have
with reversing reporter construct the
library format would will be put in this
case but of course the instrumentation
changes as we now also need to include a
fax order as well as an nga advanced
level of screening are really large
single or image based phenotypes or
screens in which the library as I said
is array so each one has a different
knockout that of course requires a high
content instrumentation with imaging or
plate handling so now having a medically
this technology established in the lab
and we wonder how far can we go with
this technology and by meaning by saying
this I mean can we go truly genome wide
I mean before people have you have
generated genome wide libraries although
one has to be cap cap cap over the stern
as it only means coding white and genome
wide is a different meaning of coding
like and what we media is really truly
genome white so basically generate your
agent that not only targets the coding
but also the non-coding region of the
human genome which of course the vast
majority of obstinacy and to do that we
took advantage of of the literature and
we are identified where people have
identified a nucleotide preferences fork
of SP caste 9ng RNA sequences we took
this information and we translated it
into you paste code and those are shown
here and by doing so we basically
generated a partially randomized illegal
nucleotide that are specific to target
highly active at peak asthma in target
sites in the human genome and if we take
this information and we translate it
into new pack then this is the sequence
an Orisha
that you will come up with it has an
estimated diversity of 7.3 to the power
10 the training sequences so it's very
very diverse but nevertheless by having
this illegal nucleotide sequence by an
oligonucleotide provider it will still
get all these different primers so what
we did is we did apply the primer to the
two classes to lentiviral chris podcast
plasmids that i mentioned to you before
Pawlenty died and clinically Criswell
version 2 we performed the reaction and
then we made the library and also
sequence the library so of course it's
not possible to sequence this library in
its full diversity but we minority
sequences and when we did that we looked
at how frequent are indeed
you Titus each year on a position this
is shown here on the right hand side and
as we would have expected at position
one next to the pan we have an
enrichment for ng Y Z and T at this
favor and this then translates into au
pair code of our and now I hope if we
walk hope you appreciate that if we walk
through all of these sequences then we
re identify the same you Peck code as we
had originally put into the synthesis so
the demonstrating that we have generated
at least a sufficient diversity in this
library and in theory this library
targets at 20 million SP cosmo in target
type and the human genome services that
was about 20 orders of magnitude or even
more higher than i even two hundred
times higher than what has been done
before we then when almond made a lot of
virus of this library and to really make
sure that we have at least a certain
degree of library representation and in
this case we did eight different
reactions that we pull it and we
dumpsters put a big library that we put
we performed a several transaction to
make Lenti viral particles we then
collected all of these together and
generated roughly 500 millimeter with a
tiger of ten to seven or ten to six
excuse me 55 million under the title
I tend to say we then took that and
applied the same blanket very pure very
strong selection positive selection
again using our RP oneself with an my of
one and the selection was essentially
doxorubicin resistance from which we
knew before that one micromolar
destruct would sufficiently top kill Li
cells within three to four days and it's
highlighted here on the right hand side
so we waited three weeks after
doxorubicin or within in presence of
doxorubicin and we considered every cell
that would still be alive on the plate
to have some sort of resistance
mechanism in place we then harvested
results and we sequence the grna s or
the sequences that we that were
contained in there we did this in
biological triplicate and we were able
to identify an overlap of roughly 4,200
sequences while the individual
experimental overlap was fairly low
nevertheless we were able to identify
experimental overlap and of course now
the question is how is this knowledge
that we generate which is sum of
accessible and we say that with this
reagent you will be able to identify
another coding and non-coding
therapeutic target for example and in
this case the target would be
doxorubicin resistance we then made a
new library and this really is the power
of this technology with very iterative
so we can you generate each reagents
very rapid and so we took now these 4200
sequences made a new library and perform
the screening again and this time we
applied the gold standard or established
for experimental Condor
of my point - and also experimental
coverage of 1000 and waited again a
three weeks in the presence of
doxorubicin and here we can see that
again we identified roughly 2,800
sequences that were able to be really
fighting the screen of which about 800
where again are rich by by by by more
than twofold
and those we now consider basically
experimentally validated so now the
question is here of course where do we
need sequences reside in the human
genome and and we did look first for
recording targets and we did identify
several of them also independent
dependent on mismatch of course at peak
at 9 is not a clean enzyme so we have to
take at least two of poverty into
account or two mismatches at least and
by doing so we did identify several
genes and among them was one particular
gene that was interesting to us because
it had previously been published to be a
doctor robust and resistant marker and
the stream is called sis LG are true and
on the left side and when this is a
Wiesenthal interesting well it's also
interesting because there are two
chemical compounds available targeting
this gene or protein and when we take
those compounds they are shown here on
the right side and called biases a g2 or
Bayou 973 we take those compounds and we
tie take titrate them in into
doxorubicin into including
concentrations of doxorubicin what we
could do is improve a lately reverse the
toxicity of doxorubicin and chemically
been getting our pioneers yet and
however this were only the coding target
and of course more interesting were the
non-coding ones and when we now look at
a non-protein coding what we could see
is might just click on the next slide as
well so we have a summary here we did
see of course unknown left side we did
see of course also an enrichment in in
history while allowing mismatches what
is not too surprising however
overall we identified a lot of predictor
promoters of Kings long non-coding RNAs
antisense pseudogenes ctcf binding sites
which has been previously reported to be
important in this context but also
transcription by factor binding site and
predicted and Hanza however I would like
to draw your attention to the very
lowest part which is the biggest pile of
the biggest part of this pie chart were
actually 52 percent of all of the
sequences that we identify we were
unable to identify any any and so we
could map them but we there was no
annotation available so we know that the
sequence is doing something with respect
to dr. Lewis algorithm but we don't know
what the function is at this particular
site and this is of course ongoing in
the lab and to build invalidated on them
individually and see what is going on
there so now this was what we call the
TGV library that truly genome-wide
library and a positive this is very very
big and probably too big to handle so
what we did is we generated an optimized
version of this and by saying that what
I mean is that we use the truncated
version and this has been shown before
truncate the grna so down to 17
nucleotides have been reported to be
similarly active then guide with 20
nucleotides in length and this is shown
here so what we do basically is we
deleted the first three nucleotides and
thereby not so much affecting the the
twenty million target set in the human
genome by dramatically reducing the
diversity of this reagent and now making
it very feasible to actually screen
these reagents in the suspension or even
an adherent M itself we generated this
reagent on one length and Pawlenty died
as a kid on t Christopher into the pure
as well as with a GFP marker and those
reagents are fully and fully partially
again also a quality verified that we do
by the electrophoresis and also
yes and this is showing you an example
for the polenta crisp aversion to
library where we did confirmed by NGS
again the new petticoat that we had
originally put into demonstrating that
we have these reagents at hand and we
are we are sharing them and if you would
like to read more about this then I
would kindly ask you to also to look at
the publication that we are referring to
here so now we can very rapidly and with
high confidence generate high-quality
unbiased single guide RNA libraries and
we do have at hand many many yeah
validated reagents targeting protein
families as well as genome-wide
libraries so if you're interested then I
would to kindly ask you to get in touch
with us but I was now spend also for the
remainder for the remaining time of my
talk I would also like to address an
issue that is coming up and one more in
the field of genetics training which is
the field of synthetic lethality or
multiplex CRISPR screening and this is
showing you an example what this means
is basically that let's imagine for a
moment we have two genes in which the
knock out of either one so the Nugget of
gene a or gene B and does not enforce a
phenotype but when you knock them out or
when you interfere with their
functionality simultaneously within a
single cell then you establish a
phenotype and why is this important well
of course it is important because we
would like to understand some paddock
utility for example of a drug
combination but also it is very
important for pathway redundancy many
protein families are and roil intention
to for example Ju between e to or III
line basis there's a lot of redundancy
in this pathway and it would be very
interesting to figure out what are the
single essential one
and then what is the next level of
combinatorial sensor combination
however the limitation here really is to
generate those reagents and if you look
into literature you will find a handful
of papers that have that are using data
that used conventional current learning
technologies to generate this reagent
and you will quickly realize that the
footage of this reagent is nearly what
it should be and which is why we of
course now use the VCF technology that
we have at hand in testing whether they
work for my reflux
perspired library generation and again
this is very similar to the skin that I
showed you before we basically now have
another thing not a single but a double
G on a expressing plasmid and we we use
bacteriophages again to extract a single
stranded piece of DNA we now in near and
not a single illegal Poobah - which is
highlighted here by the two different
colors so now the orange one will become
extended towards the green and the Green
will be extended toward the orange one
that I generated the heater will duplex
and also within this process you'll you
generate all possible combinations
within those individual to it then you
have the hero duplex you transform it
into bacteria and there where you
generate now a combinatorial library
again which is the same speed and
robustness as for single libraries and
again of course I would like to show you
this on an example here what we did is
we tested this on the example again of
GFP nm sherry and the community for a
combination and what we did here is we
took a roughly 120 illegal nucleus
oligonucleotide or gr and a's g elements
for GFP and roughly hang with a 24 inch
re by doing so we generate
14,000 or 15,000
combinations with it by simply mixing
those two prime important ow into a
single super single-stranded DNA
instead of single port and then you wait
two hours and then this is basically a
reaction product that you see on there
on a job again I would like to stress
that we don't do any PCR or cloning here
and then what we do is we purify the
plasmid and I mentioned to you already
before what we do is expensive quality
control or reagent and doesn't show you
about electrophoresis of this
combinatorial reagent and I alluded to
you before that we are using these
homing enzymes or switching and landside
in our template to make sure that we
have that we can get rid of any wire
that bacteria may be unable to degrade
and this is shown here so when we on the
right hand side of course the MD
backbone will be pleased with both
enzymes because both grx passing subsets
are basically wild-type but if we now
introduce the gene or G GFP encoding
audio nucleotides here
then the ETA one side where I saw one
type is untouched so the the plasmid
cannot be linearized by the SC one side
is linearized and vice-versa this is for
the entire panel and all the other
cassette is linearized while the IFC one
side is untouched
however most importantly in the
combination of GFP and sherry so when
you add both primer put into a single
tube then in the multiplex you don't see
any linearization
miniqueen suggesting that this side has
um both sides that completely being
randomized and changed so we of then of
course can also sequence this and this
are shown here we do quality control
plus by NGS and this is the multiplexed
combinations of / - jion expressing
cassettes one having an h 7sk promoter
the other one having an HS six promoter
and this is not really demonstrating the
full diversity and also distribution of
this combinatorial library so first of
all it is complete but it is also very
nicely distributed with an A or C of
0.68 M are those reagents functional
that's of course the question here that
are shown on the right hand side we now
turn the focus reagent or reagent and
transduce them into GFP m jo+ expressing
salt and if we do that with the gfp
alone virus and then wait a couple of
days and then go to the facts to readily
see what is the content of or the
percent of reverse and positive self you
see with the gfp only library we only
target the gfp expressing and if we do
that with m ferry we of course only
reduced and cherry white in the
combinatorial in the combination of gfp
presenter we target both genes within a
single cells and ultimately
demonstrating or suggesting
functionality here so now this is of
course only a GFP and sorry but i also
like to share with you no more yeah
another example that we have
unfortunately I will not be able to tell
you what exactly the library on the
experiment was suffice to say there is
an enrichment screen so we use a
fluorescent reporter that enables us to
enrich for a certain phenotype and what
we do here is we generate a library a
combinatorial library of protein family
and we screen a this library first on
its own so that means we only target the
individually so it's not a combinatorial
reagent first but it's now a single
libraries just targeting those genes and
then in which of those genes when it is
deleted induces the phenotype that we
are interested in we have done this now
in duplicate and there's a sub
correlation again and we do that to
basically identify the single essential
genes for that phenotype this is the
correlation for they're highly
correlated and then we do this with the
multiplex library or the combinatorial
library and of course you immediately
appreciated the high abundance of
absorption which already tells you that
there are much more is to be expected
but of course also with more
combinations in here to give you an idea
of the design so the single library on
the left hand side has a size of roughly
900 guide while I'm here on the right
hand side we have a combinatorial
library of about 250,000 combination and
we then of course applied by our
computational another analysis and we do
outlier analysis to readily perform it
calling and when we do that what we see
here is that roughly a 20 genes and
those are shown me on the left side in
blue have a phenotype in single
condition but if we now take those
single hit and deduct them from also
deduct them from all our multiplex or
combinatorial that we are left with
roughly 600 gene-gene interactions in
which none of these genes is essential
on their own to induce the phenotype but
only in this combination induced the
phenotype so now this of course a lemon
so that these reagents are highly
functional and of high quality and I
would like to conclude from this of
course a few learning objectives here so
first of all what defines 3 CS gene
editing reagent so first of all I hope I
have convinced you that there is no
sequence bias in these reactions and
indeed in these libraries that is
cloning free so there will be no cloning
neither kids very fast highly
reproducible it's versatile as a drug
for Christmas as well as far as HRH
they've shown you and highly reduced
cuts and this is of course relevant
because we only need a single
oligonucleotide Foggia RNA instead of
two then also which formats are
available of a single I mentioned to you
and of course also multiplexed a format
and we have validated reagents away at
hand and I have another site that will
goes more detail here but of course we
are also always willing to generate
tailored reagents and single almighty
clicks a performer
validated reagents that we have
currently available of course the
optimized truly genome-wide library and
several different backbones and we have
a coding white library that does coding
white libraries we also have a lot other
validated pledge that I mentioned before
to you protein family at hand for
example kinase as phosphatases
a tumor suppressors the entire debugging
machinery at Apogee etc a GPC arts of
the list goes on and on so if you would
like to know more or different please
just contact us and Google to be able to
communicate the do full list or in the
North Pacific team and we of course also
offer tailored in height and
hypothesis-driven reagents in singular
maybe text format and they come
depending on your needs with and without
the care line and of course also with or
without the selection or fluorescent
marker and I said as I said before if
you have questions on this then please
contact us at vision at info at the
on.com so now of course we can do this
reagent them and some people would ask
okay what is it good for and this is why
I would also like to share with you some
applications for these single and
compare multiplex reagents for new your
course synthetic interactions can be
identified and this means either gain or
loss
we can you can do positive or negative
screens depending on the phenotype that
you are selecting of course to it or
right this makes a big difference the
poetry agents can be can be easily
generated in singular
well it might be place performance but
of course the rate libraries um are
easier to generate and single format
them in my duplex because numbers go up
very rapidly
of course applications are tinglin
multiplex screen so what can get we will
do of course we provide validated
libraries as I mentioned before targeted
libraries for a specific set of genes
that your interest and they are unbiased
and of course we provide them in Chris
podcast format that GRS or an RNA is a
journey and of course we would also
offer a screen so in case you don't have
the ability to do this in please
approach us and we would be able to
communicate this with you so with this I
hope I have convinced you that we have a
very powerful technology at hand that is
proprietary to our company and also to
the lab and and that we can certainly
generate a single and multiplex
libraries then in various formats that
we have pre validated libraries and that
we also offer screens with this I would
like to close again I would like to
remind you to contact us if you have
questions and I'd like to thank you for
your attention
and my last slide maybe you can keep
this in mind Viviana neighbor basically
the next generation gene perturbation
with that I thank you very much for your
attention and I'm happy to take
questions